anger on the streets of peru's capital
lima protesters are demanding that
spanish oil giant repsol lose its
operating licence after nearly 12 000
barrels of crude oil leaked into the
pacific ocean just off the coast of lima
we are outraged by the pollution and
we're going to continue the nationwide
fight that's why i'm here i want repsol
to leave for all transnational companies
which have only come here to steal from
us to go away
the spill happened while a tanker was
offloading crude oil to a refinery
repsor says the pipeline was damaged by
the tsunami triggered by the recent
volcanic eruption near tonga
but government officials say the ship's
captain doubts that and protesters
accuse repsol of spreading
misinformation
just like thousands of other citizens
we've come to protest against pollution
and against the lies repsol is peddling
it systematically said that the damage
was minimal then said it was as a result
of the tsunami then it told us the
incorrect quantity of oil spilled
the environment minister has banned
repsol from unloading oil until further
notice he also wants guarantees the
company is properly maintaining its oil
pipelines
first we call for a halt to all
hydrocarbon loading and unloading
activities in the peruvian sea by repsol
until it provides us with technical
guarantees that no further damage will
be done to the sea that belongs to all
peruvians
repsol says the decision is
disproportionate and unreasonable it
says it's hired more than 2 000 people
including local fishermen to clean up
the polluted beaches but many peruvians
won't be satisfied until the government
orders repsol to leave
victoria gatenbee al jazeera